we had an extraordinary debate in the  working group with the citizens  speaking about our common  goals to build a stronger and more  social  europe we were speaking about the  important topics for us as a minimum  wages as a  include  decent salaries a decent work how can we  improve the economic growth in europe  without a forget the social dimension it  was wonderful debate with the citizens  and now we need to put on the paper this  conclusion trying to to  have a strong  proposal for for the future and now i'm  going to the plenary to to listen our  participants who want to speak about  young people about education about all  these important things that in this  exceptional moment we have to to  exchange and to share  trying to build more europe and a better  europe